hey guys it's canine Friday April 29th
I'm Mary this is Simone and you're
watching gamespot news top five so our
fifth biggest news story this week was
that Nintendo announced that the NX is
coming out next year in March Nintendo
has confirmed that its upcoming gaming
console codenamed NX will be launching
globally in March 2017 the information
was revealed as part of the company's
2016 fiscal year earnings report the NX
release date was also confirmed by a
post from the official Nintendo of
America Twitter account the report reads
for our dedicated video game platform
business Nintendo is currently
developing a gaming platform codenamed
and X with a brand-new concept the NX
will be launched March 2017 globally no
further details about the NX or the
consoles concept or design were revealed
nintendo announced that the upcoming new
Legend of Zelda game will be released
simultaneously for the wii u + NX in
2017 the company also revealed it will
be releasing fire emblem and Animal
Crossing games for mobile devices the NX
will not be making an appearance at e3
this year sorry y'all our fourth biggest
story was the witcher 3 s teased image
of blood and wine which was really
gruesome so you have little kids have
them look away now the world of the
witcher 3 wild hunts blood and wine
expansion may be colorful and vibrant in
some sections but as the story synopsis
teased there's a dark foreboding tone to
the content as well developer CD Projekt
RED has shared an image from blood and
wine that shows garel standing over the
body of a man who's literally ripped
apart with what appears to be yeah
that's his entrails in a bucket blood
and wine will deliver a fascinating
story that contains every sort of twist
and turn you'd expect from our writers
developer said recently about the
content which is set in the new region
of Toussaint The Witcher 3 s first
expansion was called hearts of stone and
came out in October CD Projekt RED
previously said the witcher 3 s two
expansions combined amount to almost the
size of witcher 2 holy crap blood and
wine is expected to offer around 20
hours of gameplay compared to about 10
for hearts of stone no official date has
been announced our third biggest story
was
lizards failed game Titan and how they
quote failed miserably Blizzard designer
Jeff Kaplan has opened up about working
on Titan the cancelled mm oh that was
positioned as the studio successor to
world of warcraft the project was
officially announced in december two
thousand ten but remained shrouded in
secrecy before ultimately being
cancelled in September 2014 littles been
discussed about it until now speaking in
an interview with gamespot Kaplan said
Titans development team failed horrific
ly in an experience that was unfamiliar
to developers that had previously helped
craft some of blizzards biggest titles
you had a really amazing group that was
working on Titan he said they were
really talented individuals but we
failed horrifically in every way in
every way that a project can fail it was
devastating gamespot published a series
delving into the creation of overwatch
which is blizzards first new IP in 17
years over the course of three episodes
Danny O'Dwyer talks to key developers
about the inception of overwatch further
explores the failed Titan project and
discusses how the team is channeling
classic online shooters you should
totally watch them they're amazing but
like after this video speaking of The
Witcher our second biggest story is how
cyberpunk 2077 is going to be even
bigger than the witcher they even quoted
oh my god oh my god CD Projekt RED has
yet again spoken up to talk about the
ambitious nature of its upcoming RPG
cyberpunk 2077 in an interview Martian
of Vince Key says the massive success of
the witcher 3 wild hunt which has
shipped 10 million copies btdubs gives
the developer more resources an
opportunity to go even bigger with
cyberpunk 2077 the game will be more
ambitious on every single front in the
development and on the marketing side he
goes on to give the raddest quote I've
ever heard if we look at our role models
what Rockstar is doing is amazing it's
not like we have to ship a game or we
may not hit our financial goals it's
here's GTA 5 and by the way it's the
best game we've ever made we're all
looking forward to red dead redemption
too because you know they'll show
something and you'll be like oh my god
cyberpunk 2077 is due to arrive sometime
in 2017 to
21 but we really don't know because we
know it'll be done when it's ready first
a leak now a runny faucet our top news
story of the week was the leaked name of
the next call of duty 8 also that you're
getting another game when you get that
game call of duty infinite warfare that
is reportedly the name of this year's
entry and activations first-person
shooter series it'll include a
remastered version of call of duty
modern warfare according to this image
of a pre-order card the image was posted
on reddit and looks to be from a US
retailer target probably it shows the
cover for a legacy edition of the game
and states the package also includes
call of duty modern warfare remastered a
November 4 2016 release date is also
prominently displayed triple leak
although Activision an infinity ward
have not officially revealed the game a
listing for it appeared on Sony's
PlayStation Store Activision typically
fully reveals this new Call of Duty
games around April like now so it's
probably going to happen so those were
our top five news stories of the week I
hope you have a rad weekend I will be
back on Monday as jess is on a
top-secret super mission so I'll see you
guys then in a couple days goodbye